so hi everyone and thank you for coming
my name is Adi and I work here at PayPal
as a data scientist and my job is to
develop machine learning algorithms for
fraud detection now PayPal is known for
being a safe and secure and however
maintaining this reputation requires
hard work behind the scenes of
developing fraud detection algorithms so
think about our problem as we have a
transaction payment and we want to
detect if it is fraud
or not now as our algorithms perform
better and better in production we
understand that we want more the final
model score is not enough for us and we
want to understand the story behind the
model decision so think about this
example an inconclusive score the model
predicts 50% chance for this transaction
to be fraud ok why we want to understand
is it further or not we don't really
know what to do with 50% chance so for
example if we could break this model
score into how much every feature
contributes to the decision we can get
more insights so for example here maybe
there is inconsistency with past
activity maybe the user connects in a
different time of day than she usually
Shops at so this can increase the fraud
chance and however she does use her own
credit card and she sent the product to
her house so that decreases the front
chances and we reached that point five
decision when having all of this in our
mind we can get more interesting
insights about this transaction maybe
this is a traveling customer therefore
the inconsistency but it's the same
person so this type of explanation is
part of the law
field of explain ability I this is a
huge buzz word coming up and it's the
next big thing I think in machine
learning and I am personally very
excited about that and to explain our
models can help it can help us a lot to
get more data insights to debug our
models understand when they are wrong
why and maybe if you are all modeling
process because if we train a model and
you just check on the test at the back
teeth we don't know what is really going
on there so okay we are good engineers
but if we understand why our models do
and then we can change them according to
our path analysis we can get much better
models in our place maybe less time and
this specific type of explanation that I
showed you here breaking the model score
into feature attributions this is called
local editing feature importance and it
can be calculated using shop shop goal
of Cisco okay so shop stands for shop we
additive explanations and it is a method
for local feature importance local
because we explain a specific instance
at a time now the input for shop is a
training model F and the specific
instance X the output of shop is an
explanation for every feature we get the
contribution of this feature to the
model score f of X now this is local we
say we expect specific instance at the
time and it is also additive because the
sum of all contributions is exactly f of
X so our goal in this talk is to
understand how she does this what is the
type theory behind the tension and also
how can we leverage up to get insight
about our mother's shaft theory is
exciting
it is based on chakra values from game
theory they were defined in the 50s by
Lloyd sharply he was an economist a
mathematician and he also won the Nobel
Prize for economics in 2012 so think
about a game this is a cooperative game
played by a few players together and
then by the end of the game they reach
specific amount of money the question is
how do we divide the money between these
players in a fair way assuming each
player contributed differently to the
game so what is a fair way Shapley first
defined fairness properties he defined
that a fair way it means an additive way
it means that the sum of the money the
old players get together should be the
game result and consistency that if one
player contributes more to the game she
cannot get less money the most exciting
thing in shop I think is the thing that
sharply values were proved to be the
only unique solution for distributing
this money keeping the fairness
properties of course we can distribute
the money however we want but if we want
to keep the furnace properties it must
be sharply values what are sharply
values now we go into the details
sharply values for player I shaft Li
value is the amount of money that this
player would get how do we calculate
this amount we count the marginal
contribution of this player it means
running the game with and without this
player but for every possible subset of
players again F is the game M is the set
of all players s is a specific subset
and we run over all possible subsets and
is our player that we want to decide how
money should she get so we take a
specific subset of players now we
calculate the game result for this subs
with and without our player I and then
we do this averaging over all subsets of
players and this is shuffling values and
average okay
now we're gonna take this to the machine
learning settings and okay before I want
to highlight this is the only solution
for being a fair distribution of money
this was proved theoretically now we
take it to the machine learning settings
and this is the I think the exciting
thing that Scott Lang burg and swingley
from the University of Washington
published in 2017 they published their
first shaft paper and they said we are
going to adopt chocolate values into the
machine learning settings now F is a
model M is the set of all features s is
a subset of features I is a specific
feature and we want to it to explain how
do we give this feature its importance
its contribution not to the game to the
model result okay X should be the
specific instance that we explain as I
said shop is a local method we explain a
specific input instance at a time so we
are now explaining how much feature I
contributed to f of X so how we get you
take we count over all possible all
possible subsets of features and we
calculate the model result on the subset
with and without feature I we this okay
we we take the difference between those
two results with and without the feature
I and then we get a specific marginal
contribution we have rated over all
possible subsets of features and this is
the sharp value for player I a for
feature I so now by following the
definitions of chakri values and this is
what sharp outers proved we are
following the definitions of chaplet
values and there
we are the only unique solution to
distribute the contributions of the
features by and keeping the fairness
property so this is the only possible
solution to keep our addict tivity and
consistency of the feature attributions
method ok that sounds perfect
perfect we have a very good question
[Music]
this is a perfect question okay I'm just
talking about it okay so we have two
questions to make member big challenges
here first I told you we should count
for every possible subset of features
now every possible subset is an
exponential time and this is a problem
right it's not practical if we have a
large number of features of our model
the second problem is I told you and
this is exactly what you asked you
should run a model with missing features
I didn't say you put null I said missing
features no features how do you run a
model with part of the input is missing
this is a big problem and therefore we
need the chef's algorithms to solve it
and out this is what I'm going to
explain how do they solve in different
options these two problems for you to
have just an intuition what is the most
naive way you could calculate chop
values okay just train a different model
for every subset of features now if you
train a different model you can run it
with the features you trained and that's
it it's an exponential of course and you
have to train it's not practical but
this is very nail and just for intuition
now actually this doesn't solve our
problem because I want to explain my
model in production if I retrain a
different model for every set of
features this is not explaining my model
this is explaining some feature of the
data some characteristic of the data and
now this is specific very interesting
thing and if you want to read more about
it and you want you should go to Eden
say hi
Adams pose I give
here on the link and this is exactly the
subtle issue he explains okay so let's
focus we want to calculate additive and
locally accurate additive feature
attributions we want to keep the
fairness properties we want to calculate
the shop values but we have challenges
so how do we solve them so to our best
of luck this is exactly what Sharpe
package in Python does they just
implemented a few algorithms made
actually they implemented a lot of
algorithms I will explain a few of them
to solve these challenges so you can pip
install shop it has a very user-friendly
API actually as you seen this piece of
code you don't really have to understand
anything about what is going on behind
the same to apply shop you just do shop
dot something chop-chop values blah blah
blah you have the shell values well I'm
going to explain is what is going on
behind the scenes which algorithm you
want to choose what do you have to
supply as an input and more interesting
thing than just a flight so the first
algorithm I'm going to describe is the
kernel explainer shop kernel explainer
is an algorithm which is model agnostic
you can apply to every function it is
serves nothing about the model however
it calculates only approximation of the
shaft values not exact values why
because instead of going over all
subsets of features
it's just sampled some of them so it's
an approximation and you decide how much
subset you want it increases your
runtime accordingly how do they deal
with the missing feature problem this is
more interesting in my opinion they just
say ok we cannot just reduce features
from our model so let's just replace
their values with with something that
you as the user tell us which is a
background your the user should decide
what is your background data set and
this is an interesting question I'm
going to do to describe here
and your supply it as an input to the
shaft fair method and it just replaces
values take the missing features that
you have by the shop and equation it
replaces now with features from your
background data set with values from
your background data okay so what that
crime data sets people use okay yeah I
just I have it here so thank you so
there for example people use their whole
training set now if I replace the values
for everything I have in my training set
you understand that it increases run
time also so maybe just a second you
maybe you want to do just a kit means
approximation of your data set or
something like this people use the
median of the data set if they
understand that this is the bank good
background or for example for images you
might choose the all-black image or
something like this but you should
decide what is your background and if
you don't decide you just run it with
something and you hope it's gonna be
fine
now the thing I wanted to highlight here
about the background is that there is a
story I cannot give you specific
instructions this is the background you
should use as more things inexplainable
AI this is an open question nobody
really has a real answer to how which
background should you use but I have a
story this story is a real story it's
taken from a github issue actually if
you're interested in shop values go to
the github issues and start reading them
people ask Laingsburg a lot of questions
and the answers very nice and
interesting and well answers and it's a
very good resource so this specific
issue after I incorporated it in my
presentation I understood that this the
person that asks this question easily
act and she's the researcher PhD student
in Bangor on doing a research about
explain ability and she couldn't come
here but yeah
her question about the background
dataset so what is the question she said
I have a sparse data set for example I
have measurements of body parts of
measurements for the lung and from the
head so this is a very sparse data set
and for example I have a feature
indicating if this measurement is coming
from the lung or not now I want to
explain an instance a specific instance
from the lung which background should I
use so if you choose only lung
background you're safe in terms of the
distribution you are not going out of
the distribution because this is a long
distribution this is actually not true
because in the language you also can
have some secret senses and some
requirements about the distributions
well let's say it's simplified okay so
however you want to replace the East
line feature with something and you are
not going to replace it with anything
other than one because this is what you
have in your background so how would you
understand the impact of the Islamic
feature if you cannot replace it with
anything else however if you choose the
old data set as a background then you
are safe in terms of you are going to
replace the Islamic feature with zero
but you might go out of your
distribution very very fast and I'm not
going to talk about it this is a very
big issue and I don't have a solution
okay so this is about the human data set
now another very interesting thing about
shop kernel expert okay yeah so in short
word the question was can I explain the
purpose of the background dataset so the
purpose of the background data set is to
provide you values to replace missing
input in the shop formula you have to
run your model with some input missing
you have to sample subsets of features
and when you have a subset it means that
part of the features are missing out
from your model and how do you run a
model with missing input you have to put
something because the model should mean
something to run so the the option for
the option here that the shop outdoors
found is okay we just
with background and those will mimic
missing features I didn't say that it's
the best way but this is their way so
another very interesting thing about
Karen or explainer is the connection
with lime lime is another featured local
feature attributions method and actually
it was published a few years a year
before shop
what line does is to train a linear
model that approximates our model but in
a very specific point in the local area
of our point that we want to explain
right this is a local method so they
train a linear model to approximate
their big model just in a specific area
of the of the of the distribution now
what is this area what does it mean Boca
so they have a kernel function to
describe locality but this journal
section is not provided to you you
should use whatever you want this is a
knife a hyper parameter now shop others
proved that if you run line with their
specific kernel you are actually
calculating shaft values so this is the
connection between them and this is a
very interesting result because then
they can use the line implementation of
running linear regression on the area
around your model around your instance
and you with the locality of their
kernel and then you get shot values okay
another very interesting algorithm is
the three explainer now you can apply it
to only three based models by click
calculate exact check values in
polynomial time and this is a very very
interesting result how do they do it
intuitively how do you run a tree with
missing inputs so you traverse the tree
run right you traverse the tree to run
the model now you encounter a specific
are split and your input is missing so
you don't know where where you do need
to go so you just go both ways and
recursively sum up the results average
the resultant
this is intuitively their algorithm to
mimic missing features in a tree and
they keep track of the tree traversal to
avoid repetitions and therefore they
manage to calculate all subsets
but in polynomial time because they
remember things in the middle okay so
this is a very elegant solution and if
your model is tree it could be random
forests it could be a gradient boosting
could be activists many many things are
supported you should first try this one
because if you should supply no
background and it runs the exact job
values in polynomial time
so for trees this is better for deep
learning models for neural networks they
also provide a different algorithm and
this is really out of the scope of this
term because it's a very complicated to
describe I would just say the very basic
intuition they use a connection with
another algorithm which is called deep
lift they calculate shape values for
small parts of the network for example
just for the linear part just for a
nonlinear function with one input they
calculate analytically very many many
shock values in the network and then the
dip list is being used to back broke-up
back propagate all of this knowledge of
these shock values locally to get some
values for your input so this is not a
good explanation how it works but this
is just an intuition and you are
encouraged to read papers okay so many
questions there the question was if the
results of shaft values of of deep
explainer is an approximation yes it is
an approximation
why because you should read like the
paper okay and you also should provide
some background data set but for
different reason and we can discuss
later okay so if you lost me so now you
should wake up this is my take home
story about the shop method about the
shop algorithms and then I'm going to
move to the practical part so we need
loca we want but actually we need local
additive feature attribution many
methods
to solve it I mentioned lime I mentioned
deep lift there are much more however
only a unique solution can satisfy
additivity and consistency and this is
the Shapley values calculating exact
chaplet values is hard shot provides
approximation for all models all
possible models in an approximation with
the kernel explained and considering
tree based algorithms you can calculate
exact Chapel use in polynomial time do
it and for new networks you can use the
dip explainer which uses some connection
with the deep lift algorithm ok perfect
right woohoo okay now if you are going
to use shock values you should just know
that if you have a lot of or some
correlated feature in your data set you
can get unexpected results I will give
just one short intuition now because we
don't have a lot of time but for example
if your model has two identical features
I just replaced the name but it's two
identical features trained on the label
now if my model uses just one of them
so shop would attribute all the value to
the first our first feature x1 and x2
would get zero shop values however if
the model uses both sometimes x1
sometimes x2 you cannot control it you
can try but not every time you can
control which correlated feature your
model uses so then you might get your
shop value split into two and if you
have not two correlated features maybe
you have ten because you have I don't
know thousands features for your mother
then your shop values might be split
into very very very small amount and
then you're gonna think that this
picture is not important because it has
a low shot value and it's not true
so because shop is additive you can sum
up things
together and it's it's fine you can do
it so maybe this is a solution but you
should think about it correct
okay this is the practical part what do
we do after we calculate your values so
now I will mention one thing this is
also an open question I didn't see many
people talking about what do they do
with sharp values maybe they calculate
them and just show them to their
customers maybe they change them a
little bit to be more expected and then
they show them to the customers but I
didn't hear many people and I am looking
for it so if you have a story let me
know after what I want to hear people
really using shock values for doing
something so one thing you can do with
sharp values is one thing one basic
thing is to just investing investigate
one specific prediction as we talked
about now one more interesting thing you
can do is to aggregate a lot of shock
values for many instances and see some
global view of your model and this is an
example I'm going to show there are many
more things you can do you should go
into there Ghita propose see the example
see the notebooks they have also an
outright paper explaining a lot of
aggregation I'm not gonna explain all
over them I will dive deeper into the
central aggregated explanation so yeah
we get some kind of insight but once you
get from the higher level you get
another inside it's not correlated maybe
they eating each other so you can get a
let's say it precise the discussion what
is going to happen in production about
your order what is affecting your
results because if you see it in a macro
level you would have some idea but if
you see it in a low level if you just
mentioned that there is a difference
between
the local or the global view they are
not the same they are not providing the
same insights of course of local or
global ok local I can talk to you later
but I think it's a much more trivial the
you digit of local you have a problem
your model predicted this is a fraud but
it is not it's like the paper CEO and
you blocked it and then ok you get like
someone's escalation what did your model
do
so you want to investigate but the
global I will showcase one thing here
but there are much more cases if you
want just google it and see many people
try to explain and what they do with
global and views and I can also say
before joining paper I was in I did my
masters in it it on single Islam and
about him personalized nutrition and
personalized medicine and hug I feel so
much and they used a lot shop values in
the global view to investigate some
really medical features so you can take
a look as well of their papers and ok so
you see this view and if you are using
shop values or someone in your office
uses shop values you're gonna see it
because it's very easy to implement you
just do sharp values dot summary plot
and you get it it's very easy now what
is this quote and why do we see here so
let's break this plot into details and
understand why do we see here so look at
the left side of the screen you see the
whole plot every row is a different
feature i said i'm aggregating shap
values for many instances and also for
many features what is the color the
color is the actual feature value for
example maybe the first feature is age
and so red values are older people and
blue values are younger people what is
the x axis the x axis is the shock value
now you can see it in the zoom in
the shock value can be 0 it means it
didn't actually impact the model result
for this instance but it can be high
positive value it means it pushed the
model in the model output up and it
could be minus large negative value and
it push the model output down so you can
see a lot of things here for example if
you take the right blue dot you see that
it has low value like a young person but
high shock value so it increased the
prediction
however you look to the left you look to
the left then you see a red dot this is
an old person with negative shock value
it decreased the model score you look in
the middle you see many values and you
see that the thick bars it's just a
distribution it's a jitter of the dots
many many dots every dot ISM instance
and you see many features that didn't
actually impact the model many many
instances for them the edge feature
didn't really impact the model so again
if you take a look on the global view
you can see something you can see some
pattern in your model and I will show
you a specific example how we use this
here every row is a single feature this
is an aggregate for 20 features ordered
actually ordered by their min absolute
shaft values so that we take the
absolute because it could be negative
and positive so the absolute here in
represent the importance and we can sort
the values by their mean and mean
absolute values and then you see the
most important way the 20 most important
features for example most important is
developer actually q what does it mean
most important but with higher ash a
higher mean shock value impact okay so
what is our specific fraud case so
obvious is here she worked on it
this is a specific model we trained to
predict fraud of course and we used only
a specific type of features features of
consistency you can imagine that
consistency is important if the person
is more consistent it hi it is an hi a
higher chance for it to be the account
holder and if it's inconsistent maybe
this is a fraudster
so why consistency features do we have
for example cycle time consistency
product consistency and many consistency
features and we train the gbt gradient
boosting tree to predict if this is
fraud or not very trivial supervise the
scenario now we apply the shop values on
the results of this sound algorithm for
on the test set for example and we got
this plot now why do we use this
platform to gain trust in our model we
want to see that our model uses features
in the way that we as we have the domain
knowledge think it should do not all the
time you have domain knowledge not all
the time you know what the model should
do but sometimes you know and you want
to check that this is what your model
does in addition to test your accuracy
and everything so what our model does am
our model take the blue dots to the
right it means that people that are
inconsistent with their past are more
prone to be fraudsters and this is
reasonable you see that the red dots are
going mostly to the left it means that
inconsistencies in the account are more
reasonable a consistencies in something
very consistent in they can't is more
probable to be the account holder and
the fraud chances are lower so this is a
very global view I didn't say it is
correct for every single prediction
maybe even say that this is the way
every feature should look at but this is
the global view and it can help us get
trust in our model and just for a small
I think though so if you run this week
random data you don't see this pattern
and this is also a way to debug whatever
you want and if you see the random data
you see much more dotted pattern that
it's not just all the Blues go here and
all the red go there it's much more mess
messy and you should maybe investigate
your model maybe you chose the wrong
version maybe this is not your data set
I don't know but this is a very very
easy way to implement something they
gave you a very nice global view of your
model ok that's it our motivation was to
look inside the black box shop is a very
nice way to do it
it is theory based we can trust it we
can know what it does it's not just a
heuristic and it has a very practical
implementation so it's very easy to use
it has a lot of applications you can
investigate local model scores you can
see some global view but they are much
more if you take a look at recent
conferences you're going to see a lot of
people trying and starting using shop
values in more advanced ways for example
to find shifts in your data set to find
there is one paper discussing who is
more responsible to the score the model
or the data there are much more
implications that are starting to pop to
show up and therefore I think this is
increases the the importance of
understanding what our shop values
because there are some kind of bases
they have they have a lot a lot of
citations to their paper many people
starting to use it and if you don't
understand this
it will be harder to understand all the
applications on top of it and so that's
it and I should say that personally
machine learning explained abilities
very interests
topic for me and I really do it now
these days we are working on a project
on how do we use tools like shop and
more to explain models but in an actual
in an actionable manner for example I
don't want just to see the values I want
to do something I want to help my
customers understand the predictions use
them better something like this and if
you are working on explain ability or
you doing some research about it please
send me a message I really want to
connect we are started connecting people
from this field and I don't know
creating a sub community or something
like this
and so I would be happy to take person
the question is if we use it for
multi-class problem so I think yes why
not you want to explain the prediction
and you mean multi-class whenever you
predict few possible outputs I didn't do
it but I
everybody is someone as an announcer
yeah it works we work ok
I said yeah yes ok so the question is
there is a lot of criticism about using
external method to explain models
actually this is called post hoc
explanations you train a model and then
you try to explain predictions and there
is a criticism about a lot of
explanation thing this is an ongoing
research there is no like there way to
explain things my view is that you
should first define what do you want as
an explanation like what is your
audience what do you try to explain
there are many different solutions one
solution can be to train a more
transparent model there are models like
this IBM of Microsoft if you heard about
it but the problem of these models for
example in PayPal I won't change all
people's production models now right I
have already very good models Exxon
is like the next level but first level
is to prevent fraud so this is where the
postdoc explanations are really really
useful yes just to make sure I
understood in the last couple of slides
you showed an example where the model
where you measure their sensitivity of
the model not just to the existence of
the feature but whether it's present or
not but to the actual value how sedative
it is to a certain age range so how does
it implemented actually you only make it
the feature disappear okay what what I
show here is the actual shop values
after I cut every dhoti in this plot is
the final shock value after you did all
of this
subs sample subsets and missing features
and that that's the final shock value
it's the average of the marginal
contribution of this feature for this
instance so you calculate it using the
shop algorithms I showed in this lecture
this is actually the shop values you get
the final result of plunk shop we can
discuss later okay yes okay you asked
why do what am I looking for when I'm
looking at this specific plot so this is
a good question there is no one answer
specifically in this model we try to
make sure that the model is using the
feature in the way we think it should it
should use the consistency in one
direction inconsistent fraud not going
to a consistent not fraud and if it
doesn't do it it's a specious something
is weird maybe it's some overfitting or
something like this but for different
type of use cases you might be looking
for something else
here we just looked at the pattern okay
so I'll be happy to take questions later
and thank you very much for listening
[Applause]